that is their role and their responsibility
especially here again tonight suer will play
it back in K's on it P to the front
they score Jason sucker and he was
set up beautifully by the Pittsburgh
kid Logan kolie and it's one- nothing
coyotes it's one of his his former teams but
look at the play there by L and coie he turns
his stick over and just shovels that puck across
that was leang I believe he wins the foot race and
the puck battle and then how about the Finish
By zooker it's something else is Conor Ingram
will steer it around Jeff Carter is there as
he intercepts behind the net they get it to the
ball to save Ingram kicked it away back out high
for dery dery to the front T night Lang here's
Crosby he's in on a breakaway syy Crosby stopped
by Ingram can still fly and this time he's bested
by Conor Ingram Matias melli will send to the
corner Krauss with it now out high durit and
now Lawson Krauss going right back to the front
trying to poke it in with mad he takes a shot and
oconor is on him aren't afraid to get into the
mix there's a shot by kuss and bues that hacking
and whacking for it set play there latain excuse
me Carlson tried to fire and here's a chance Zer
is in Zer to the fraud he's stopped and a rebound
Dumba and jar V Penguins now chasing a little bit
here's the play I was talking about carison just
stops completely skating and hopes his defensive
partner is going to bail him out as zooker just
says thank you very much I'll take this Puck to
the net looking for his second goal of the hockey
game Dumba and now Malin back out high as he'll
let it go for Carlson coyotes have it here's
an opportunity and cres in and a stop by jar
oh Carlson has the puck and krow recognizes the
turnover Josh Brown try to move it along denied
turnover here po Joseph hustles it back over the
line and now a shot towards the front it's loose
and they score and they've tied it at one that
might be po Joseph's goal and the penguins are
level Penguins will take it I think it's going to
be ell there's the original shot and Conor Ingram
has all sorts of problems hanging on to this Puck
as it bounced off a couple players that's why it
went off the left glove and off the stick I think
of brown and right into the left pad of Conor
rdam and that puck just kept bouncing bouncing
ended up behind him and just finds its way in
the back of the net slowly so an innocent shot
brought along melli little drop Keller Keller
still with a puck back out High it goes valami for
Keller to valami and fr Stars youo valami welcome
back balamaki set up by that man right there
Clayton Keller watchs the ship draws every M
to him he's not down there again everybody goes
to him and that leaves valami wide open in the
middle of the ice and Clayton Keller Under
The Stick of Crosby onto the Stick of Alami
and into the back of the net look at that face
six straight games as a healthy scratch comes
in brought back by Crosby dumped in Moser
trying to play it along all over a Malin
is Krauss goes by behind at Crosby feeds it back
out High Carlson now for Crosby ticks it in and
scores Sydney Crosby's tied the game at two all
right this isn't even fair one of the best that
ever played the game Watch the Chip Shot literally
like a little nine iron little whack at it look at
how far away he is from the net bad angle almost
on the goal line and just kind of swipes at it
and that just back to Center lawon Krauss but the
beauty of it for the coyotes is they're spending
a lot more time in the offensive zone comes in
front Krauss with a Shot Pat save jar back in
front coyotes bringing some more heat here they
score and it's Alex Kook and he gets it right
back and it's [Applause] 3-2 just hard working
in on the for check for in turnovers Puck some
people to the front of the M BL jari never able to
really get set again lost his footing almost kind
of tripped back into his net caught himself and
kerit says thank you very much look at the work
though by zooker has a goal and an assist in this
one and now Gib will back out High Marcus Pon now
for leang right back to the front oh and a stop
somehow that stayed out Ingram got the rebound as
well side door incredible how this one stayed
out played away there Carter trying to get it
out coie stepped in front of him to keep the
Play Alive now Keller to the front [__] is
there oh and he can't put it home and he went
hard into the crossbar oh he got hammered what
a second effort Clayton Keller making some magic
happened down low look at that silky little pass
to kie in front it's his hometown team gets hug
tugged from behind so they got Crosby back on
the ice L Tang's got it he'll bring it along in
the delayed penalty this is big for the Penguins
they're just trying to kill as much time off it
went in oh my [Music] [Applause] [Music] goodness
the goalie pulled leang has it he goes back to M
it and Malin can't handle this back pass it goes
off the blade and into the back of the net and
Whoever touched this Puck last for the coyotes
is going to get the [Applause] goal that is
incredible I certainly have never seen that
before and Rael will help it back ell's got it all
the line suits to a stop and a rebound and they
can't get it the second C Carlson to the front
here's look at that time for Rael and now McBain
with a little bit of time as it's brought along
O'Brien drops it buad is in he scores Nick buad
52 [Applause] [Music] coyotes little high flip
by McBain Liam O'Brien little backhand feathery
pass to big Nick bu dad hits double digits here
stays on the forehand little Chip Shot over the
glove he waits for jar to drop elevates it right
underneath the bar tries to go high off the glass
and move there by Keller and he moves it along
for melli butelli to the front oh a stop Jarry
on buad Lo goal his 10th of the season and the
coyotes aren't done speed driving the net and
taken away by gper and the coyotes will look to
move it out B steals it away side of the net oh
what to stop Ingram robbing ER Conor Ingram laying
out unbelievable approving this stop Eller almost
got his second Carlson now off the face off
brought out meli's got it moves it along for
Gunther Gunther is in Gunther stopped by jar and
a bre take away look here for Dylan Gunther in a
5-2 [Music] game and the coyotes earn a season
split in their Series against the Pittsburgh
Penguins and that is it at the mull what a team
effort tonight for head coach Andre turn's group